[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen bei allem ein
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt
ich habe heute feminine unterstützung
von meiner freundin hinter der kamera
die auch dabei ist letztes jahr ungefähr
um diese zeit kam von mir dieses video
mcdonald's monopoly also wir waren mein
weg ist haben sie ein bisschen
eingekauft hätten also bist du mehr
da hatte ich auch glaube ich einige
helfer also sich ging es einfach nur um
diese monopoly teile weil man kann ja
mal einiges gewinnen und das machen wir
jetzt
bevor wir allerdings losfahren wollte
etwas zeigen und zwar hat mir lag damit
ein gutes paket zugeschickt ich schaue
es mir selber jetzt erstmal an die haben
auf jeden fall einige frei gepackt
alternative macht das vorstelle auf weil
die ganzen sachen handelt sich ja um
laser blaster das cool ist man kann die
unterschiedlich miteinander kombinieren
wir haben insgesamt acht verschiedene
kombinationsmöglichkeiten dass die wäre
das einfach die erste david der laser 15
meter weit
wenn man dann das erste stück
hinzugefügt haben wir schon in lhasa der
20 meter weit geht
dann haben wir noch weitere pakete das
aufschrauben und irgendwann kommt man
auf 50 meter laser
[Musik]
und ich glaube das ist das heftigste man
hat zwei verschiedene möglichkeiten man
kann einmal im trainingsmodus spielen
und dann auch gegen andere dass sie sind
die zielscheiben die kann man dann zum
beispiel hier anbringen oder man stellt
sie irgendwo auf und spielt im
trainingsmodus das mache ich jetzt
einfach mal so leute hier kann man auf
training stellen ihre stimmen wir das
jetzt einfach hier an der wand hier kann
man jetzt den laser aktivieren dann
wählt man hier ein pda oder b auf einmal
nachladen leute wird es jetzt noch
einmal von der ganze mist da das sind
ungefähr 15 meter sollte ja locker
knacken und das teils glaube jetzt
zerstört also leute ich verlinke ich
einfach mal die website zu den laser mez
um in der beschreibung und auch einen
amazon link wir mal die auch kaufen kann
passen vor weihnachten für ihre
geschwister vielleicht sogar freunde
man kann ja sogar auch so ein kleines
trinkspiel raus machen wer weiß also
kann auf jeden fall auch für ältere
lustig sein und muss noch mal also
soviel bis hierhin jetzt machen wir
weiter mit dem video und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß
sie erzählt mir von der neuen hilfen
fall gutes wetter heute
wir fahren jetzt ja
die westlichen angucken wir fahren jetzt
zurück und kaufen eigentlich hab mir
gerade im kopf eine kleine liste
erstellt das machen wir jetzt 15,2
szenen ab für taschen
es ist ja noch getränke und ich wollte
ungefähr wieder auf die summe von
letzten jahr kommen ich glaube das waren
so knapp 100 euro
und dann schauen und dann schauen wir
mal ob was gewinnen letztlich habe ich
nichts gewonnen
dieses jahr gibt es dann habe ich wieder
viele coole sachen die man gewinnen kann
vielleicht haben wir glück also bis
gleich so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie
lange wir heute warten müssen
halo ist ein bisschen mehr und zwar für
mich einmal 15 große pommes 15.15 genau
dreimal curly freis dazu kommen noch
fünf große kohle und noch zehn
apfeltaschen
danke
15 15 also lassen sie hat mir glaube ich
sogar noch ein ganz bisschen mehr ich
bin mir nicht sicher
bayer macht wird das auto wieder einmal
drei wochen hat max
also ich bin mal gespannt so leute wer
hätte es gedacht jetzt musste ich
natürlich mal wieder hier vorfahren
dauerte ungefähr zehn minuten ich habe
zur sicherheit noch mal die
mitarbeiterinnen am markt weiter gefragt
ob gerade auf dieses monopoly ist
einfach nur um sicher zu gehen und sie
meinte ja letztes jahr hat genau an
diese mcdonald's hier eine familie die
hier urlaub gemacht hat 20.000 euro
gewonnen und ich habe gehört dieses jahr
sind wir doch in spanien waren so sowie
haben wir alles schwierig schwierig hier
die balance zu halten wie im zirkus oder
also hier wäre ein paar getränke und das
hier sind die ganzen typen
ich bin erstmal gespannt alles hat jetzt
insgesamt 980 euro kostet fast 100 2000
jahre später
wir haben eigentlich mal aufgebaut als
letztes jahr hatten wir halt nur pommes
dieses jahr haben wir nicht nur
kommission was ja gut finde ich glaube
diese abbild und kosten nur 1 euro und
da gibt es gleich auf zwei länger
truppen abziehen
und da haben wir direkt schon mal nichts
gewonnen also für sagen wir fangen geld
man wenn man die leute die sich fragen
was machst du denn jetzt mit dem essen
wäre es natürlich selber ein bisschen
und ich muss jetzt gleich noch in die
uni und da freue ich mich schon einige
über ein paar leckere pommes du hast
gewonnen als vettel oder ein soft finden
jackpot ich bin mir jetzt unsicher ob
man diese codes sondern auch einlösen
muss ja widerlich
ich mache einfach mal hier mit der kohle
arbeiter sofortgewinnen einschicken
burger oder ein filet und tisch und
haben eine neue straße
das ist cool was ist cool checken naja
ich müsste ja 80 schicken bürger
gewinnen damit ich dort hier wieder
hause noch verhaltener ab sofort
gewinnen als oder software also heute
drei sofortgewinne aber schon kumpel
haben wir machen da kommt man weiter
irgendwie zieht man hier mal alles ab
schon wir haben sofort gewinnen also
sofort gewinnerin festnahmen an
einfachen weißen 1 max handel oder einen
cappuccino hauptbahnhof wieder gehabt
gepäck und jackpot coating also die
checks ich bewahre mir die jackpot codes
natürlich mal auch und die gebe ich euch
mal einen nach dem anderen steht der
erwartungen
also diese straßen die mag ich ja gar
nicht wenn da kann man nichts mehr
anfangen
und schon wieder nur straßen wieder nur
zwei straßen
wir ziehen jetzt einfach zusammen ab
sofort mir das hier in stuttgart jackpot
warten wir den bayerisch du musst aber
auch dass da oben behalten dabei oben
sind die grenze ist also zum beispiel da
liegt sie bei prof
also da muss ich erstmal die bestellen
sofortgewinn eine pommes und oder einen
kaffee schon wieder sofortgewinnen eine
pommes klein oder einen kaffee bedanken
[Musik]
und ich mache wieder an sofort gewinnen
gab es war knapp aber es war ja ein
gewinn nach man hier sagen wir sind blöd
hat man von straßen leute werden das
jetzt hier auch eine kleine pommes isst
oder einen kaffee dann war einfach in
der ganzen reihe das gleiche drin
das ist aber nur ein jackpot rekord also
die gebe ich gleich mal ein vielleicht
hinter die chance auf 20.000 euro
die sandstraße und support gewinnen
hüte oder oder die landesstraße ich habe
dieses war von einem kalipreis und
jackpot dickhaut ja danke
und hier haben wir wieder den jackpot
und hier auch wieder kommen muss wow das
ist noch dreimal habe selbst mein körper
gibst dir einen okay und ich gucke mir
zu und hier ist wieder so eine blöde der
straße
so hier haben wir einen sofortgewinn 1
max käse das turnier auch gut ist ihr
direkt einlösen oder wenn sich alle
profis gegessen hat und noch einen
sofortgewinn eistüte also leute
anscheinend haben wir schon alle auf
gemacht oder
wir haben bestimmt fünfzehn
sofortgewinne und 15 jackpot chaos und
ich würde sagen wir geben wir erstmal
ein mal gucken was rauskommt aber
erstmal was ich noch ein bisschen
sechseinhalb stunden später haben jedes
match verloren bisher irgendwie
miteinander an einer verlosung teil
damit versuche einfach mal ab man was
zweimal antreten kann kann ich hatte den
ganzen tag hier ansatz ist hier gewinnen
also ich denke mal dass es nicht geht
heute kein einziges mal waren außer ein
paar sofortgewinne fiel letztlich ja
geil das mit dem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen gibt dann nach oben und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder ist
wahrscheinlich ein neues video also
heute haut rein kämpft auch gern bei
marie was gut